[Music]
christmas comes
early from fox news podcast i'm dana
parino and i'm chris dyerwald
and this is perino and starwell i'll
tell you what is this
christmas in july yeah because it's or
a day earlier in the week now everyone
can rejoice
i i don't know about you but i it's like
my life is just scrambled eggs this one
change
and i'm like wait a minute and all
morning i keep forgetting
that today's the day to do it and then i
remember and then i forget everything
else and then i come over and do it
i'm i'm like uh in sixes and sevens
i mean imagine how the people are gonna
feel when they get the notification that
i'll tell you what
it's ready for them and they're like
wait but it's not wednesday but
i'm feeling like it might i'm thinking
this might help me
to deal with my scheduling situation
this is our this is our fond hope and
i will the good news now the good news
about it is aside from
giving america i'll tell you what a day
early the good news is
this just makes tuesday like
everybody has a day a day of the week
this for me just makes tuesdays like do
this and then dude like you get up early
and you just do it
and then it actually wraps up pretty
early my day wraps up pretty early on
thursday
it's just a pen to post throughout so i
kind of like those days
because you're in a sprint yeah yeah man
i'm sprinting i got
i've been getting up earlier uh because
i have so much reading to do and stuff
and also it's so earlier are you
delivering milk now
are you getting up at three
no i i had been i had been getting up
around 6
20. decadent that's way too late for me
even like
i would wake up at six and i would read
you know
emails and stuff like that until 6 20.
but i was like i need more time
to read and i have stuff to do and i
have emails to respond to so
today i got up and i set my alarm for 5
30
i woke up at five i got out of bed at 5
16
and i came downstairs um and we have a
porch and you know it's been so hot here
in the mid-atlantic
i sat outside it's like probably the
only time i'll be outside all day
and that got more done i want to be
clear that when i say i
am getting up early on it got up early
today i mean
6 30 and i felt like i was
making a sacrifice for the people so
let's i'm i'm not going to get carried
away
i will not be on the milk crowd i used
to love when we
would get the milk from the milkman
because it was put in a little
box um underneath our mailbox and right
about
right below where we had our american
flags line on our house on elm street in
denver
oh that was good milk and really good
stuff great
nestle's chocolate quick the powder of
course is better than the hershey syrup
sorry hershey
oh have we that is so true it's very
true
why is that i don't know it's uh i think
but nothing better than putting the
powder on top of the frozen ice cream
i find it too gritty i'm not gonna lie
to you oh i love
the grit i love it i find it too gritty
um i haven't had that in 35 years
probably
the better solution is to take
um haagen-dazs cherry ice cream
cherry vanilla ice cream and in a tight
scoop and then roll it in cocoa pebbles
oh yeah i could see that i could see
that
oh it's but i didn't but we didn't get
coco pebbles we would get
if my mom allowed us to sneak it into
the cart and pretend she didn't see
fruity pebbles fruity the cocoa and
fruity pebbles are both
great garbage cereals and i'd say that
with real affection
um and cocoa pebbles way better
than uh coco crispy all of the other
and but the real point of those cereals
is to produce the chocolate milk in the
bowl
that is the that is the goal oh see like
i would i i didn't drink the chocolate
milk
in the bowl for some reason i just
didn't do that for some reason
oh you just i even let it steep a little
bit
no way that's just okay now you've gone
too far
maximum and you're gonna force us to
talk about politics
today to brianna we were getting talking
about what are we gonna have in the note
where are we gonna blah blah blah blah
blah
and we're getting we're trying to get
together our house ratings
and i said you know today's not the day
because we're doing the podcast and
stuff we'll get to it this week
and i said plus uh today's news is like
a niagara falls of hot garbage
and i meant i meant that in a positive
sense
you know i i don't know what other
businesses are like ours
but on days where civilians
look at the news and go ugh
[Laughter]
i of course look at the news and go yes
easy yeah there's so much
while we're recording attorney general
bill barr is delivering his
opening statement which is was very well
written well
um i'm sure it's well delivered though
he's on mute right now because we're
recording a podcast
um but this was a this is going to be a
showstopper of a hearing because
everybody wanted to talk to barr the
republicans want to defend him the
democrats want to bloody him and there
are some legitimate questions that need
to be
asked and gone over and hopefully this
hearing
will provide a lot of answers are you
looking
into are you looking in for particular
anything here
in this hearing no i i have i have
no expectations i assume it will be a
pointless exercise
in uh partisan chest thumping
but a lot of news for your hot garbage
well the news
is we got the republicans trying to get
their
bailout package together um and
basically
they're coming to the negotiating table
with like three pieces of a broken coke
bottle five marbles
uh some gum they found and they're like
let's make a deal
and we've got uh the president uh
tomorrow going to campaign in texas
which is tells you something we've got
unrest in america's cities we've it's
like
and now we've got the teachers union um
i think the largest teachers union uh
saying that they'll back strikes
um nationwide strikes if they have to to
prevent reopening oh did they say that
yep uh that that their members think are
unsafe
and it's uh it's going to be
it's going to be a hot ticket and you
can see
that between the fight over the urban
unrest um and
the school reopening we think by by the
time we get to labor day things could be
pretty ugly yeah gosh i didn't know i
didn't hear that about nationwide
protests jesus louise
i'm kind of interested in these um uh
what are they what are they calling them
the underground schools
that people are trying to put together
and the reason i'm interested is i do
think that the pandemic is going to
force
some change that a lot more people will
become
more comfortable with homeschooling
school choice
um i am concerned about what happens to
lower income families with children who
don't have all those options to move to
a
beach town and put their kids in school
there
and what happens with the teachers and
the funding everything it's a really
fascinating
issue well you know we should uh of
course
always preface by saying that for you
know the
bottom third of earners uh those of
limited education and limited means
everything that happens either good or
bad good things that happen for the
country as a whole
they benefit less from and bad things
that happen to the country as a whole
they suffer more from
uh it is uh the poor will always be with
us and
um it's we should always remember
that on the other hand the
decision by google for example that
their employees aren't coming back until
next summer
they just said you know what we're not
doing it um
for knowledge workers for
a lot of american the the promise of
connectivity
was that it would make people more
flexible in their lives
that giving us the gift of the tools
also that
we would all get along so well and
everything would be perfect
that's right we would connect and
harmonize um
but the promise was about things like
what we're doing right now
which is there are uh six of six of five
of us
six of us uh gathered together over
an internet connection to record a
podcast
that then will be shared and nobody ever
has to go into an office somewhere
except for bonewald sorry bonewald uh
the
that promise wasn't much realized right
uh if you would have asked 40 years ago
a futurist to say what is going to
happen
in the united states a clear option
would have been people
aren't going to have to go into the
office as much that the distance work
will be more possible
small town small communities out in the
country people can live where they want
to live
um i think we're going to see that and i
think we're seeing it now and i think
we're going to see it in part because
families will figure out ways to get
through this neighborhoods
looking for ways to educate their kids
are going to do logical things
like sign up for homeschooling online
resources
like band together to provide physical
activity like
i guess i'm just an optimist about
human potential people figure stuff out
in really
impressive ways and the people who
for millennia have bet against human
progress
and human potential have been proven
wrong over and over and over again
if you like that there's more where that
came from just download perino and
stairwell i'll tell you what
at foxnewspodcast.com